i think we there we go we hello everyone
we are live
gonna turn on
the old live thing over here checking
connection going live on
the instagram welcome welcome welcome
everyone hello instagram how are you all
welcome but
knocked over my phone there
uh
welcome welcome welcome i'm excited to
do
this live q a i haven't done one of
these since we had book club and i
noticed a lot of people signing in oh my
goodness the dakota potato uh peel pie
and literary society book club good to
see you back
haven't seen you in a while it's like
reconnecting with old friends
um uh love that there's so many people
from book club who showed up today so
hello good to see you all and just an
amazing array of uh countries we've got
india pakistan why aren't you guys
sleeping you should be asleep right now
uh brazil morocco spain indonesia
switzerland germany uk all across the
united states wales florida portugal
miami i love this this is so amazing
everybody's coming together and my
favorite part is saudi arabia this is
fantastic mississippi i love how
everyone is saying hi to each other in
the chat i love that too we truly are a
community of people brought together by
common cause i love this we are live on
facebook instagram youtube linkedin all
the places uh we're gonna do some q a um
and we can just jump right in notice my
new hoodie
uh got this new hoodie that we made we
we have a drop today as well let's check
out what it says we took it can you see
it probably it's all there we go do the
re there we go it says the goal is not
to be perfect by the end the goal is to
be better today super super comfy um we
just had these made because i think
they're nice um and if you want one
we're having a drop today um so we'll
put that link in the
in the chat if you
want this we only have one option we're
just doing one because i think it's cool
okay let's jump right into the q a
uh
let's jump right in um hello jeremy
hello chile denmark this is amazing
sweden amsterdam
illinois i want to make sure now i go to
all these places that's even more from
edinburgh love edinburgh okay uh dr
heath jolif asks
how do you coach others to overcome
their fears during periods of change and
transition
such a good question i love the desire
to serve there um
so
one of the things that we're always so
tempted to do when people are going
through change in transition is we want
to tell them what they should do we
constantly want to give them advice and
push them and encourage them and tell
them and though it's well intentioned um
it's not always the helpful thing to do
and so really what we need to do is
create a
safe space for people to just let it out
and so we have to get become actually
the strange thing is be better listeners
than speakers yes we will have our
chance to speak but you'll find that
most people actually know what to do
they just need to sort it out in their
head themselves and so what we want to
do is ask questions like what are you
going through how does it feel tell me
more what do you think you should do
does that feel right what do you think
you should do tell me more go on and
what you're doing is creating a safe
space for them to get all of the stuff
that they're uncomfortable and insecure
about out on the table and that's how
you help someone go through a period of
change or transition become a good
listener okay um
apparently my focus is out of focus so
i'm going to put my hand in front of the
camera
and it should refocus because it's
autofocus okay there we go
um another question should we take one
from
the side of the thing here
from walt from other chats hello geneva
here's one that's just came in thank you
can you come a little closer um
what was the most impressive real story
you have witnessed regarding leadership
change for the better and why was it a
success oh that's a really good that's a
really good question the most impressive
real story so i i don't know if it's the
the most impressive but there's a bunch
of impressive stories that i've heard
you know very often
you don't have to be born a great leader
you know a lot of the really inspiring
leaders that i've met
are people who sometimes screwed it up
for decades and they have some sort of
epiphany or realization that something
has to change um whether it was um like
i've written about bob chapman uh bob
chapman who's the ceo of barry way
miller one of the companies that i love
it's a manufacturing company and they
lead with a what they called truly human
leadership which i absolutely adore um
bob was one of those accountants who who
just saw people as a number
and he was actually at a wedding um and
he had this epiphany where he watched
the ceremony play out in front of him
where a father ceremonially walked uh
his daughter down the aisle gives her
away that's the ceremony the giving away
of the of the daughter and then goes and
sits down
uh and and and traditionally that uh
young woman will
give up the name of her family and take
the new name of of her husband um this
is the tradition as if you're moving
from one tribe to another as if the
protection that was guaranteed by the
father how must now be guaranteed by the
new husband this is the tradition of a
wedding and bob is sitting there in the
audience uh in the pews and he has the
sudden realization that every that this
this father is giving away his precious
treasure to somebody else to look after
and he realizes everyone who works in
his company is someone's uh treasure is
someone's uh uh
son or someone's daughter and they're
giving their children to him to look
after and he realized that's not how
he's been treating his people for
decades and so he had this sudden change
of how he should start leading and he
went on the journey of becoming a
student of leadership um i was just
talking to a young entrepreneur a couple
days ago who's 25 years old and he's so
inculcated in the traditional way of
leading you know he was he was pushing
back on me he's like well investors this
and wall street that and and and what
i'm realizing is that once you go
through transition um it really takes a
tremendous amount of courage because the
system as people think it is
the system is us um uh does apply a lot
of pressure on us to do the wrong thing
so that's one of my favorite stories is
the one above chapman uh here's another
one from molnar edlud um how do you
start to motivate the people around you
towards a goal when you're not the ceo
great question
so remember leadership has nothing to do
with rank or position
um just because someone has a position
of leadership does not make them the
leader
leadership is the awesome responsibility
to take care of those around us so your
question molnar is how do you be a
leader if you're not the ceo you don't
need the rank to be the leader you have
to study what it takes to be a good
leader and you take care of those around
them so you can share vision whether
it's the companies that you believe in
or whether it's yours um you can share
vision with the people around you even
if it's your boss somebody uh who is who
works for you or even your peers it
doesn't matter you can lead all around
and you can do all the things that a
good leader supposed to do in other
words be the leader you wish you had um
and you'll find that strange things
start to happen in your little community
and you're a little group i've seen it
happen multiple times in organizations
where these mid-ranking leaders take it
upon themselves to be the leaders they
wish they had and those teams become the
highest performing teams and those teams
become super super tight-knit and before
you know it that starts to spread so be
the leader you wish you had uh
hello ontario canada um
here here's a question from elena uh oh
i just lost it elena pastawa where are
you i lost you
we can pull it up here it is uh what are
the most important things for elite
leader to do when starting a new company
or team great question so this is such a
common mistake that a lot of uh young
young leaders do when they're starting a
team or a company is they start talking
about how different their product is
yes that's important but what's the
context for that different product
what's the origin story why was the
organization started in the first place
i see this happen so often where
especially with young startups they're
so driven by their investments and their
revenues and all of these things that
even when they're successful they forget
all the team building start early right
um uh
start talking about the vision
immediately start talking about why the
company was formed what challenge was
faced say what your ambitions are for
the team what you promised to do for the
team i will be there for you give you
the resources you need offer you top
cover
and also push you and encourage you uh
to push yourselves and here's what i
expect in return i expect honesty i
expect you ask for help when you need it
do not expect you to solve all the
problems yourself we're rooting for you
i'm we're all rooting for each other we
want to see each other succeed so you
can talk about what you promise and what
you expect back from your team start to
create the the community
immediately and then talk about it
obsessively you can still talk about the
product and all those things but now
they have
context
um
drew barker how are you drew um what are
you most proud of
um
that's a good question the you know i'm
proud of the fact that this community
exists to be honest
you know i love the fact that um that we
that i really feel a part of something
bigger than myself that that we everyone
who's on here we are the army who
believes desperately in this vision of
the world in which the vast majority of
people wake up every single morning
inspired feel safe wherever they are and
end the day fulfilled by the work that
they do
and we've taken upon ourselves to be
accountable and we are building the help
others industry
you've heard me say it many times before
there's an entire section in the
bookshop called self-help and there is
no section in the bookshop called help
others we're building the help others
industry we're teaching people the
skills
to take care of others
to consider others points of view and by
the way if they learn those skills
they'll take care of us it's much more
of a circle i'm really proud that these
ideas because of our army are taking
hold the fact that the concept of why is
now in our vernacular where you hear
people and companies asking the question
and talking about what's your why you
should learn your why and many of them
have no idea that it that it where it
alright where it originated i'm really
proud of that i love having an impact on
the world where people actually don't
know where it comes from when i can just
sit back and watch it grow because at
the end of the day this has to be bigger
than all of us and it has to survive all
of us uh it has to go on well beyond our
own lifetimes so i'm super proud of the
fact that we have momentum for a real
real movement and we're changing the
course of business
go ahead tim tim
ted lasso show i feel a lot of the
leadership skills you teach could be
seen in the show so uh ted lou as have i
ever watched ted lasso what do i think
of ted lasso because a lot of the skills
in ted lasso seem to be the stuff we're
talking about i love ted lasso uh and
yes uh uh he does embody a lot of the
skills we talk about um he thinks about
his people more than winning um and
turns out the team wants to win he
encourages uh people to take on their
own problems and if they have a problem
with each other to to address it uh he
doesn't he doesn't act like an
overbearing parent
he uh
he replaces judgment with curiosity
we're all trying to do that i really am
trying to do that on a daily basis to
replace judgment with curiosity he asks
questions and at the end of the day he's
a good guy and he believes in
forgiveness i
we yes i love love love ted lasso what's
not to love
um
what else do we have here um ben nguyen
how does a sense of humor play into
leadership well
it's like how does a sense of humor play
into making friends how does a sense of
humor play into meeting people or dating
like a sense of humor is the most
wonderful thing in the world um because
it makes you human but there's a more
even more valuable thing about a sense
of humor which is you cannot laugh and
be sad at the same time you cannot laugh
and be scared at the exact same time and
so i think maintaining a sense of humor
especially in difficult times is
essential because when we're under huge
amounts of stress at work and somebody
cracks a good joke it actually puts us
in a great frame of mind to come
together and attack that problem to
overcome that challenge so i believe it
or not i actually think a good sense of
humor is essential to great leadership
it actually helps us come together and
and make it through adversity um so yeah
love a sense of humor
[Music]
from tracy buckley yes tracy
butler leadership styles clash among a
group of leaders as it appears to create
payoffs at times okay that's a great
question what a high quality group of
questions today um uh the question was
what happens what do we what do we do
when leadership styles clash when two
leaders have completely different styles
well remember when i talk about
leadership
and what does it mean to be a leader why
do we call someone leader like they lead
means they go first they go first into
the difficulty first into the unknown
first into the uncomfortable and so um
if you have two leaders who are clashing
in style it only takes one of them to
want to be curious about the other one
usually what happens when you have two
leaders clashing in style is they're
both trying to be a little bit
overbearing they both try and impose
they both try to explain to the other
person what my point of view is matters
without actually making the other person
feel heard the irony is when you have
leaders clashing one of them has to
actually be a little bit more of a
leader which means to back off a second
and say tell me more i want to
understand
and create that safe space and the
minute they feel heard
then they will be much more open to your
point of view and so all of that stuff
that you're really good at doing as a
student of leadership with anyone where
there's any conflict you apply all of
that stuff
um in here um i i had a i did a podcast
i recorded a podcast with the wonderful
uh william yuri
who wrote getting to yes it hasn't aired
yet it'll come out
in a few weeks
but one of the things we talked about
was conflict and here's a world famous
peace negotiator and he said there's
nothing wrong with conflict he said in
fact we need more conflict the thing we
have to learn to do is to transform
conflict so it's not about aggression or
violence or trying to be right but it's
about communication and openness and
curiosity the conflict is fine it's the
matter in the manner in which we deal
with conflict where we can do better
okay
um
here's a good question from
yes how do i lead people in my
organization who are much older than me
how do i make them respect someone who's
younger and make them take me seriously
okay so this is a classic question he
asks how do i lead people who are older
than me and get them to respect me okay
so you can't force people to respect you
but you can be really honest right um
now people who are older than you um
they have more experience than you so a
little difference goes a long way and
it's really great to simply show up to a
team um and simply say um
uh uh
you basically say what it is which is i
just want everybody to know i'm fully
aware that i am younger than many of you
i am also fully aware that you have more
experience than me
my job is to create a path and make sure
you have all the resources you need to
take care of you and make sure that you
can be the best
uh versions of yourselves and that you
can have the most success that you can
possibly have my job is to help you do
that and i will come to you as often as
possible to ask you questions and get
your point of view because at the end of
the day you know a lot more
than i do you may even know more about
this industry than i do because you've
been doing it for longer so as long as
you show that difference because that by
the way is their narrative who does he
think he is i'm smarter than he is i've
been doing this longer than just show
difference some of that's true
so make clear what your role is as their
leader you're not there to tell them how
to do it better um
and even if you do have challenges and
conflicts where maybe they're a little
bit outdated once you've earned their
trust once you've shown the difference
and recognized that their advantages in
building that relationship they'll be
much more open to your ideas too
uh
so that works really well i think just
being totally honest look i know that a
lot of you are older more experienced
than me and so i'm going to have to rely
on you and ask you lots of questions so
i can learn so um anyway try that it
worked really well
who inspired you which teacher teacher
um so the question was which teacher
inspired me i guess you mean going back
uh back to my school days um
there were a few
um i had we're just talking about one
this morning actually i had a teacher
named mr d'ambra in high school uh and
what i learned from him um was uh
concise is good you wouldn't know it
based on my long-winded answers but uh
when i write i try and be concise we we
would walk into class
and you and on the on the blackboard
you'd see a sentence just a huge long
sentence and it came from one of our
papers and you always knew if it was
yours i had mine on there a couple of
times needless to say
and he would say this sentence has 17
words it doesn't need to have 17 words
what words don't we need and we'd all
scream out and edit it and take things
out and reword it and then at the end he
goes now it has nine words if you can
say it in nine words please don't say it
in seventeen so i learned i learned to
write concisely from him and i had a a
uh another professor in college named uh
professor jacobson
um
who basically what he instilled in us is
it doesn't matter if you don't have a
degree it doesn't matter if you don't
have a formal education it doesn't
matter if someone else has more letters
at the end of the name than you do you
have the right to challenge their
thinking as long as you can do it in a
respectful and constructive way so if i
could form a good argument it didn't
matter if someone had 12 phds and i had
none i could still challenge their ideas
so i learned about the importance and
the confidence to challenge the ideas of
people who were way more educated and
way more experienced than me
so yeah those two people had a
significant
impact in my life
um
[Music]
okay someone what uh
preetha
uh says i flew to new york in 2017 from
paris to hear you speak my goodness
thank you so much
um and you have an amazing and
captivating stage presence it's very
nice of you thank you i was always
wondering um how you spoke softly but
make a huge impact with your words
the funny thing about um speaking
is that it's not just about speaking
softly it's about knowing when to speak
softly
our voice is an instrument it's a tool
and if i spoke at the same thing if i
only spoke softly all the time it would
actually become really boring and it
only spoke loudly all the time it would
become really boring too it's about
knowing about inflection and using at
the right time i always get a kick out
of people who like have speaking voice
and they go in these difficult times it
is really important for us because
somebody told them they needed
inflection except it's the same
inflection
um
so all over these years i've learned a
bunch of things that have made me a
better speaker
and one of them is about using my voice
my hands my body all of these things to
communicate so if i'm talking about
something big i'm gonna raise my voice
but if i want people to really listen in
i'm gonna sometimes talk softly softer
and slower
so they'll lean in and wait for the
important thing that i'm trying to
communicate
um
and we got so many of these questions um
we actually it's funny that preetha
asked a sort of good segue um we just
released i think we're just releasing it
oh that's a coincidence we just released
today
um
uh on our website um a uh
uh speaking class
um uh presenting class so how to be a
better presenter that i recorded and and
we and we edited it and so it's all the
tips and tricks that i've learned over
the years so if you want to learn how to
be a better presenter you can head over
and take our class and um we can do a 20
coupon right yeah i think okay so um
uh let's make it up right now so uh if
you're watching now yeah we'll make it
up somebody will figure it out um if
you're watching now and you want to go
take the class in fact you know what
let's go crazy if you want to get the
hoodie if you want to get the hoodie and
you want to get the class we'll we'll do
this is where this is where i get in
trouble uh let's do uh live 20. okay if
you type in code live 20 uh because
we're live and you can get 20 off um
you can go take my
power presentation course i don't
remember what we called it
the art of presenting you can go take
the art of presenting or get a cool
hoodie for 20 off and the code will work
uh live 20. that will go okay live 20.
okay it's in the chat okay it'll work
there you go
[Music]
watch him
great question so somebody asked about
the labor shortage that's going that's
happening right now it's a big deal in
the united states i think it's affecting
other countries in the world as well
um
and the reason for what sometimes is
called the great resignation
the main reasons that are being talked
about i think are a little bit right but
i think there's a big part that's not
being talked about
people are talking about the fact that
there's government
subsidies in some places and people are
just taking that money and leaving their
jobs that's true in some cases i think
those numbers are smaller and that money
runs out let's be honest
um
and uh and also the people sort of
following their dreams and i think
that's a small percentage as well i
think there's something bigger that
we're not talking about and it's not
something that happened because of covid
i think kovid and the lockdown was
a catalyst but i think this has been a
steady build for many years and i think
it's an indictment on most corporate
cultures i think too many companies have
been taking advantage of employees for
too long
and if you ask people how's your job for
too many years people have said it's
fine
it's fine it's never great it's not that
i'm having fun it's not i'm learning a
lot it's it's fine
and and you ask people who have a job
that's fine well why don't you quit and
find another job
and the problem is is the unknown
is much scarier than what they have so
they settle for fine
because the unknown future the unknown
what i'm gonna do next is just too scary
and what happened during covid is
some people were furloughed or we went
through a lot of stress and strain
a lot of people had their incomes shaken
um and
we got through it
like
we survived and all of a sudden the
complications or difficulty or the story
we tell ourselves about the unknown all
of a sudden aren't so scary anymore and
so now when we compare fine
to the unknown
all of a sudden i think a lot of people
are a lot less scared
of
of of the unknown and traditionally you
know
some of your lowest level employees or
your front line employees that clung
onto their jobs and were mistreated the
most that are now looking at the unknown
and saying it's not so crazy anymore and
i think i so i think part of what we're
dealing with is actually the culmination
or a breaking point of years and years
and years and years and years and years
of companies getting away
with being able to just create mediocre
corporate cultures and it's coming home
to roost so it's a period of complete
upheaval we don't know how it's going to
settle but i think and i hope that a lot
of companies take it upon themselves to
realize that they can do a better job
the companies with the best cultures by
the way though they're losing some
employees are not losing uh
employees nearly in the same numbers as
some of the mediocre ones so it's not
even bad or toxic it's just mediocre so
the great companies are not struggling
as much because it's a fun place to go
to work
uh okay
uh what else do we have here
um
anna wu asks um how can i really make
someone feel seen and supported seen
heard and supported when i can only
speak to them by phone um here's the
thing in person is a very special thing
oh got my paper i'll get it in a minute
um
in person is always great but i actually
think phone is actually pretty good
believe it or not i actually think phone
is better than
zoom
you know when we're doing zoomy things
um you know we
we fake eye contact you know i'm staring
down the barrel of a camera right now to
you it feels like i'm looking right at
you to me it's sort of weird and
personal and so often when we um
attempt to make eye contact with the
screen with their picture you know the
alignment of the camera and the screen
are not always the same so we're making
direct eye contact but what they see is
this and so now we're having a
conversation where we feel really
connected to them but you know they
can't feel connected to us
and so
or you just look at yourself um
uh so i actually think picking up the
phone is actually pretty great um i
think we're actually more present on the
phone you know when someone's not
present on on a computer you know when
they're checking their email it actually
feels rude to say to them are you
listening to me
but when we're on the phone we can hear
that they're distracted we can say are
you there are you with me here it's
actually okay so i think lots of phone
conversations
are actually really good i think you can
actually do a really good job of hearing
tone of voice and listening to somebody
and you can hear when someone's really
present and you can be really close with
them so i'm a huge fan of the telephone
and i think a lot of people started
making more phone calls during code
which i love plus you don't have zoom
fatigue staring at the screen the whole
time you can pace i'm a pacer i can't
pace when i'm on zoom my best thing
happens when i'm pacing so that's really
good have to get my notes be right back
okay i'm back uh all right let's take
some questions uh do you have any
questions on on on the instagram here
um
scrolling down what do we have here um
oh here we go
uh
25 how are you um
i love your work simon thank you very
much uh you inspire us with your wisdom
very generous thank you um from where do
you oh god this thing's bouncing all
over the place um um from where do you
i heard a recent podcast okay i can't i
i think i'm basically getting where
where does it all come from
um
i'm insatiably curious and like a little
kid i'm generally not satisfied with
most of the answers we're given um and
so for example
uh when somebody says you know trust
matters we all agree trust matters um
and we need to trust each other and be
on trusting teams but my question was
why does trust matter and the best
answers people gave me was i don't know
it just does things just work better i'm
like yeah but why do they work better
like what is trust what does it mean to
trust can you fake trust and nobody
could give me a good answer that they
were just generic answers true
just generic
um and so
that was the impetus for me writing
leaders eat last i actually tried to and
it wasn't supposed to be a book it was
just me trying to understand where trust
comes from or start with why for example
um people uh you know when i was going
through a hard time i would ask people
for advice and they tell me things like
you know
do what you're passionate about or
follow your find your bliss or live your
purpose
it's all a hundred percent true
it's just i didn't know what to do like
it's just not actionable like
do what you love uh i'm doing the same
thing and i don't love it anymore you
know um it just was just not actionable
um and so it was that that curiosity as
to as to why things work and why that
advice is true
um and so i'm i'm i consider myself a
sort of more of an anthropologist i go
digging i a lot of my work if you know
goes backwards i go look at the i go
look at history or biology or where we
come from or all that kind of stuff to
try and uncover some basic truths and
then i can then it reveals a lot of
things so um any ideas that i have are
born out of insatiable curiosity and and
generally a dis satisfaction with the
answers that exist or that i'm given and
so i have to go find new ones
um
okay here's what you're one that just
came in that wants to know how you get
your eyebrows so perfect
well thank you very much
genetics
um
uh how do you manage uh oh this is a
good one
uh vitalius
[Music]
how do you manage a manager with a
finite mindset and
blocking all culture change that is
desperately needed and many people want
in the manufacturing sector okay i get
this question unfortunately more often
than any other question on the planet
which is how do you
if if i'm in a if i'm in middle
management and somebody above me has a
finite mindset how do i change their
mindset and the answer is
you don't you cannot change someone they
have to go on that discovery themselves
and no number of anonymously sent books
will change their mind the best you can
do is take control of the things that
you can control number one being
yourself
and so uh be the leader you wish you had
very often people who maintain a finite
mindset
um it's because it's worked for them for
years and so why change now it's made me
very successful or they don't know an
alternative and if we criticize them or
challenge them all they're going to do
is dig in like if somebody yelled at you
and said that you're wrong you're stupid
you don't understand you're not very
open-minded to what they have to say and
so again you can lead up the chain of
command as much as you can lead in any
other direction so go be curious try and
understand more are they toxic and
difficult or are they just misdirected
you know if they're toxic or difficult
then you know keep us keep a safe
distance and go protect your team from
them
again be the leader you wish you had but
if they're good people they just they
just have the wrong mindset then try and
understand and then you get to share
your ideas it becomes conversation
but again it goes back to similar
answers i've given before which is you
have to create the safe space for them
to feel heard first
and even though you may have an agenda
you have to be you have to start with
real curiosity
genuine curiosity you can't just be
biting your time going through the steps
waiting for your turn to speak that
doesn't work and people can tell the
difference go and genuinely try and
understand where what they think how
they think why they think that what the
pressures are um and then
then then take it from there um but yeah
it's it's frustrating but it takes time
and if you have an infinite mindset you
understand that it may not be one
conversation that solves it it might be
five ten at fifty or fifteen
conversations because you have to earn
trust
along the way that they would be open to
your ideas um and you're talking about
manufacturing um
go go if you want to read bob chapman's
book because he's before manufacturing i
wrote about him in uh leaders eat last
um i wrote extensively about him but you
can also read his book called everybody
matters um and he goes through it in
manufacturing so everybody matters
what advice do you give yourself in your
staff around burnout okay cynthia
is asking a great question like what
advice do we give our staff regarding
burnout by yourself oh and myself um so
uh
so the most important thing for me when
regarding burnout is i have to be honest
with my team so when i'm feeling burnt
out or when i'm feeling overwhelmed or
stressed i say that out loud
um because if if i'm always putting on
like i got everything under control and
i'm you know everything's fine i never
burn out then
everyone will feel intimidated or feel
like they can't be honest about their
about how they feel i learned this
lesson many many years ago um
uh i used to work for um an ad agency
back millions of years ago
and i had one direct report her name was
cynthia cynthia caraballo and she made
me look good every single day um and i
had a habit of letting cynthia sit in on
um uh more senior meetings and phone
calls just so she could learn um because
i because i like that
and we had a very senior client
conference call
and cynthia sat just on the side
listening in
and the call went very very badly
um and at the end of the call after we
hung up i vented and i vented to my
peers which is fine and i invented to my
boss who i had a good relationship with
and i vented to this table of people
about how frustrated and angry i was
about this client and the way they
treated us
and then i turned to cynthia and i go oh
my goodness she just heard me do that
i felt how unprofessional of me and as
we were walking out of the conference
room i turned to her and i said i'm so
sorry you shouldn't have seen that that
was totally inappropriate
and she took she looked at me and said
no no no i'm so glad i saw it she said
she goes i've been so frustrated with
this client but you're always you know
optimistic and happy and you're always
strong and you have all the answers and
so i started to think it was me and
because i was creating a false
impression of how i actually felt she
started to blame herself and be harder
in herself so when it goes to burnout if
i'm honest with my team that i also have
bad days or down days or i also need a
day off just for my own mental health
what that does is it creates a tone it
creates an environment they are more
likely to raise their hand and say i'm
having a hard day i'm struggling i need
a day off um i'm burnt out if if if our
leaders lead with authenticity so that's
number one
we do a thing called um duvet days
um
where um any employee they i don't
remember how many we have but it's like
vacation days but i think we do four a
year um where if you wake up in the
morning it's like vacation you sort of
like plan ahead and like everybody knows
you're taking vacation you know stuff
like that sick days you're homesick even
if they're spontaneous you don't know
you're gonna but you're actually sick in
bed um but we all have days where we
wake up in the morning and we just don't
feel like going to work
we're just not in the mood or quite
frankly it's a beautiful day and i would
just rather go to the beach than i would
rather than go to work we all have those
days and what most people do is pretend
they called up and they go
hey i have a stomach bug you know 24
hour bug and they they take the day off
i'd rather people just tell the truth
instead of pretending or lying that
they're sick
and so we have these things called duvet
days you feel like you need a day off
you just you need to rest you want to go
hang out you want to go
play hooky just call up that morning say
hey i'm taking a duvet day and off you
go um so yeah so it starts by me being
setting a tone and then creating little
systems that people can have uh moments
plus we work really really hard to avoid
anybody having to work on weekends at
night it happens occasionally if there's
a lot of stress but we work really hard
to protect that time for people okay
that was a long answer to a simple
question
um
let's see what else we have uh oh here
he goes uh somoid cassier sorry if i'm
butchering names um
uh um how uh do how to remain positive
when you feel that things are falling
apart and criticism creativity is
nowhere to be seen
great question
um
so i went through this i go through this
now and then i mean i'm human but i went
through this in a major way during covid
where i felt like my positivity had
disappeared um things were falling apart
um and i definitely wasn't creative
and
the most the best advice i can offer
uh sumid is um tell somebody
the worst thing we can do is keep that
to ourselves
um pick up a friend pick up the phone
call a friend who who you love and who
loves you and say i'm struggling
i'm not positive
i don't feel creative just say it out
loud
if you want to look on youtube i did a
video with my friend andrea garfield
who's a brilliant coach and as as i was
going through this really dark period i
called her and asked her for advice and
i decided to record it and put it online
in case it would help anybody else you
can actually go watch me going through
it in real time and what her advice was
but what i've learned is that by
ourselves we are not very good at
solving these problems and if we attempt
to solve these problems by ourselves we
can actually make them worse because we
sit and we stew and our narratives roll
over in our head over and over and we
can find all the evidence for the way we
feel because we kind of go looking for
it
and simply having a friend that says i
got you don't worry about it who's not
trying to fix anything they just hold
space for us um
i find that we can manage those
difficult times much better and and all
of those things positivity and
creativity are much more likely to come
back please if you feel that way reach
out to ask somebody somebody and say i'm
struggling can can i just talk to you
for five minutes um that's the best
thing you can do include others remember
this is the help others industry and we
don't build trust by offering our help
to people we build trust by asking for
help um so it actually will make the
relationship even even closer if you do
that
um
all right what else do we have from
courtney mcconnell i need a drink yeah
how can millennials establish better
relationships with gen z individuals who
don't see the importance of life without
technology
oh the irony is thick
uh who what's her name courtney courtney
asked
how can millennials create better
relationships with gen z
uh uh and try to impart on them that
technology is not the end-all be-all ah
the irony is thick i love it
um
um one is to put them in situations if
possible um
where they feel what it feels like to
have genuine connection i had a
um let's call it debate
with a 16-year-old recently um where i
maybe complained that her generation
doesn't know how to have conversations
and she pushed back very hard and said
yes we do
we have conversations all the time i
said you rely on your cell phones and
social media to talk to each other she
goes no we don't i send voice my most to
friends and i wait and i sort of have to
pause me i'm like wait a minute you send
a voice memo to someone they send the
voice memo back to you you send a voice
memo back to them they send a voice
member back to you and you think this is
a conversation and she said yes because
how do we define conversation we're
talking with each other so they think
that talking
like making recordings and listening to
them in real time is a conversation
i find it to be very avoidant right um
where a you can't read body language you
can't the tone of voice is missed you
can't interrupt great conversations are
interruptive you know
it's not one than the other then one
then the other that's like a formal
debate um conversations are messy like
people are messy and that's what makes
them fun
um it's not talking at people it's
talking with people um and so i think
the the best thing we can do is just
keep doing the things that we think are
important um the good news is gen z are
younger uh so we can put them in
situations you know we can make them
take their phones away we can go out for
dinner with them and ask them to put
their phones away or take you know i do
this with my friends where we all trade
phones when we go out for dinner so when
you go to the bathroom you don't have
your phone you have somebody else's um
and you just have to like and like when
you're the one waiting you know uh you
can't check your phone you have to sort
of enjoy the surroundings but the point
is is is try find opportunities where
you can put each other you can put them
in situations where they can enjoy good
old-fashioned human contact talking and
let them experience the difference and
talk to them about their friends
this is one thing that i've had great
success with where i don't talk about
them and what's wrong with them and i
don't complain about them i ask them
about their friends do your friends feel
this do your friends struggle tell me
about how your friends deal with uh
stress
and a lot more honesty comes out about
their friends and i say how are you
helping your friends and then i i talk
about how being present for your friends
matters and they start to realize that
putting their phone away is an act of
service so don't make it about them make
it about their friends and how they're
taking care of their friends and you're
much more likely to connect and get
through to them okay
um what else
you're welcome courtney
sheila
sheila asks how do you create excellent
corporate culture in remote environments
how do you create excellent corporate
culture in remote environments which is
what most of us are still working in um
okay so
uh corporate culture like any
interpersonal relationship uh
um is a combination of lots and lots and
lots of little innocuous things right so
think about friendships or romantic
relationships you don't fall in love
with someone because they bought you
flowers on valentine's day and
remembered your birthday though those
things may be important it's lots and
lots of little things like when they
come in the front door from being out
and you get up and greet them at the
front door
or you go and get yourself a drink from
the fridge and you get it one for them
without even asking or you make yourself
a cup of tea in the morning you make one
for them or you know all these little
innocuous things that by themselves do
nothing but done consistently and over
time they really start to build um trust
and love it's the same at work you know
it's no one thing it's not the great
speech you gave in the meeting though
those are important it's the bumping to
into people in the hallway going oh how
are you or the conversation you have
going into the meeting or out of the
meeting or having lunch with somebody or
grabbing a coffee that builds the trust
and in a virtual distributed workplace
those things are completely missing and
so what we have to do is we have to do
them prescriptively we actually have to
force those little interactions those
interpersonal non-work related
interactions to happen so one of the
things we do
we have monday morning huddle where on
monday mornings as many team members as
possible will come on to zoom and we
basically go around the room
and we say what's on our heart and mind
and we answer either a funny or poignant
question that the the leader of the of
the huddle that week will pose to the
group um and there's one simple rule
we're not here to talk about work
there's no numbers discussed there's no
goals discussed there's no we have other
phone calls for that this is just about
connecting as human beings and we learn
all kinds of things about each other we
learn what people did on the weekends we
learned who their families are if they
have kids we learn about their stresses
sometimes people share happy things
sometimes she people
share sure sad things but it's all kind
of out in the open
and we connect as human beings and they
become really really valuable parts of
building the culture
not just work we also encourage people
to work together um over zoom even if
they're not actually working on the same
project just to turn zoom on and have
somebody on the screen and just go do
your work and you just have somebody
there
also zoom lunches zoom dinners we we
encourage those things we encourage
phone calls we try to use as
few emails as possible um we we try to
limit emails um uh uh as a primary mean
of communication um so we do lots of
little things but these things have to
be forced and they have to be um uh uh
prescriptive um is basically what it is
nothing replaces in person um but you
you have to and this is what most people
realize if you're gonna go to a
distributed workforce you actually have
to work harder okay moving on
um
uh here's one from sarah kinney
how do you feel about mentorship
programs for ninth grade
through early career addressing our
concerns
awesome today thank you oh you're
welcome sarah i'm glad you're having fun
so am i um how do i feel about
mentorship programs from ninth graders i
think mentorship program is important
for all graders um
um uh and again it's it's not just the
advice we give it's it's creating a safe
space for them to talk it all through
and for us to block and tackle in other
words to ask probing questions and to
ask questions that will help them see
things differently um and i think ninth
grade is a great age for kids to start
learning how to solve their own problems
and think critically
you know we can't spoof spoon spoon feed
them everything so i think a good mentor
is not somebody who just gives good
advice a good mentor is somebody who
probably answers fewer questions than
they ask what do you think about that
you know it's good leadership stuff so
yes huge fan of mentorship programs for
kids and addressing concerns and you can
talk through themes and again what i
encourage you to do when you talk to
them is instead of talking about
themselves have them talk about their
friends they're way more honest and
they're more way more um
able to reveal some of the dangers and
challenges when they're talking about
their friends because you're asking them
to be observers and part of the solution
rather than
triggering them or getting uh you know
uh touching any nerves that they that
the that they may have if you say
something so yes yes yes yes
uh what else do we have
a seal a seal yes how do you handle
criticism and stay positive how do you
stan handle criticism and stay positive
um
well i think there's two types of
criticism there's constructive criticism
and there's deconstructive criticism um
um i've learned over the years um that
deconstructive criticism or it's
basically not very
helpful
my goal is always to grow grow as a
person
to grow as a thinker to you know that i
want my work to be better and so if
somebody gives me constructive advice to
make my work better oh my god even if it
hurts i'm all ears because i know
um it's for growth um but if somebody
just says this sucks i mean like it
might be true
my work product might suck but that
doesn't actually help me make it better
and so
i'm gonna say okay what what
specifically sucks or or what can i do
to make it better the writing's terrible
oh okay well that's not helpful either
you know like tell me specifically what
makes you and i can quickly discern are
they being objective is it just not
their style
are they onto something they just and
sometimes people are bad communicators
so i don't hold everybody to the high
standard that they have to be perfect at
being able to give me criticism um it's
my job to get it out of them so if they
give me criticism i can pull it out of
them and try not to get triggered that's
the hard part
remember replace judgment with curiosity
i assume i try to assume that they're
actually trying to help me and they want
my work product to grow um they just may
be bad at giving criticism um but if
somebody like and i get this sometimes
just people say you're stupid you're a
neanderthal i've had that um it doesn't
bother me because what am i supposed to
do with that like it's literally what am
i supposed to do with that um uh but
constructivism is the best i crave it i
i i love asking people what can i do
better what sucked what sucked less um
because i'm on the path of growth
and the only way i'm going to grow is
when i have things revealed to me that
are broken or wrong or i can be better
and so i've learned to be really really
uh appreciative and open-minded to
criticisms even if i don't agree with it
i can still receive it and then i can be
like eh i don't agree with that and i
can move on i can brush it i don't have
to challenge them in the moment say no
you don't understand and know you're
wrong i'd have to be right i just have
to receive the criticism
um and be curious about what it is and
see if there's opportunities for growth
so yeah um
ask for it i think the best way to get
good at is to ask for it anytime
somebody you do anything ask somebody
how can i make it better and you start
getting used to it you start enjoying it
um here's one from k meadows uh hi simon
how oh i lost it
hi simon how do you create a learning
culture when the executive leadership
team are the are the finished article
and don't see the value in learning and
development activities for employees
thank you you're a star i love the
picture behind you thank you the picture
behind me is by a wonderful artist named
karen gerrard
uh and i think her
website or instagram is karen gerard art
i think that's what it is anyway she
does beautiful paintings like this she's
wonderful um so okay uh a lot of
executives it's true it's true they
think everything's golden they think
they're perfect so they don't understand
why everybody else needs it they think
it's a waste of money sometimes how do
you create a learning culture you do it
informally you do it on the side
i'm a huge proponent as many of you know
of book clubs you don't need to bring in
outside consultants you don't need a
budget you don't need any of these
things you simply say to the people you
work with hey what do you think if we
start a book club where we'll choose a
book that we think will help us
personally professionally grow and we'll
read a chapter or two every week and
then at lunch or after work or whatever
it is we can jump on zoom or however we
meet and for an hour talk about the book
um and uh voluntary and what you find is
three people will show up then six
people show up and eight people show up
and basically what you're doing is
you're creating an organic leadership
development program and you can ask
different people to choose the books and
they all have to be you're not reading
fiction they will have to be somewhat
related to
uh leadership or the growth or learning
new things um you can pick your favorite
authors whatever it is um
and sometimes what comes out of those is
somebody says this is really good i bet
i could teach this and then a leadership
class is born out of it so so you can
absolutely build it organically start
with a book club super easy under the
radar um and uh ultimately um sometimes
your bosses are actually more
open-minded than you think once it gets
going um
but don't worry about whether they think
it's necessary or not just do it
um
tala
how do you get rid of instant
gratification
tala asks
how do you get rid of instant
gratification
okay
the questions are really good today okay
instant gratification is not by itself a
problem
um
um it's the imbalance and uh the fact
that we're addicted to instant
gratification
over delayed gratification um and the
main reason is is because we live in a
developed technological world
um
and uh we live in a developed
technological world and everything is
about instant gratification you post
something you start getting the likes
immediately
you can count your followers
you can
swipe right to go on a date
there's very little delay for anything
it's instantaneous feedback all the time
and one of the benefits and the curses
of the interwebs
and technology is we can measure
everything um and so we can get all the
feedback immediately um and it is very
very very
addictive
um the instant gratification is
addictive because we get those shots of
dopamine each time they make us feel
good so we crave them more and so one of
the ways we can refine balance it's not
about eliminating instant gratification
but it's about finding the balance is
one
a admit we have a problem right isn't
that the first step of the 12-step
program i think i'm addicted to instant
gratification
um number two is to turn off some of the
things um turn off likes you i know we
can turn off likes on instagram these
days turn them off
in other words take away the take away
uh the addiction the addictive thing
practice um like for me i have all my
notifications turned off on my phone
absolutely every single one of them
except for texts except for phone calls
everything is turned off so i don't know
if anybody's commenting on anything
unless i go look for it and what i find
is that i'm not so reactive i go check i
get it and i leave so try turning off
all those notifications which are um
unfortunately hijacking that dopamine
instant gratification system turn off
all those notifications most of the time
um try charging your phone in a
different room than you sleep in so you
wake up in the morning and you don't
immediately go for the instant
gratification of the telephone with all
the texts coming in you'll actually go
brush your teeth before you check your
phone in the morning um things like this
wean ourselves off of it um i've shared
some of the ones when we're with friends
you know when you go out with friends
bring one phone as opposed to
everybody's phone or trade phones like
everybody takes somebody else's phone
while you're out and it removes the
temptation and that's a large part of it
and do a couple things where there are
delayed gratifications set some
long-term goals um and measure progress
rather than immediate results that
should help it's definitely helped me
um
okay what else do we have
from rank
how do you need employees that aren't
connected to your mission statement or
why how do you lead employees that
aren't connected to your mission
statement or why um obviously you didn't
hire them so we'll go with that
um uh uh
you know they're they're
they're still first of all if you did
hire them shame on you
because the minimum standards they
should feel connected but if you didn't
hire them there now you have to work
with them and you have to lead with them
lead them
you still want to find out what their
ambitions are
if
you can still be curious about why they
took the job
um you can be curious you you can be
declarative about what the organization
stands for and why it's exciting and
stay start with things like here's why i
love what we do
um and believe it or not you can
inculcate people a lot of times people
may come into a job and they think it's
hui they think it's cheesy or they don't
believe in it but they see it working
for so many other people and they see
the camaraderie of the group and they
see the people who believe how much they
take care of each other and slowly but
surely they actually join the fold um
the ones who are absolutely resistant
who are truly truly truly um uh uh
obstructionist even um they may be so
finite minded and care only about their
own personal uh uh
promotability for example they don't
care about anybody else
the group will organically
keep them on the side for their own
safety
but you still have to try and get to
them
you know like i said lead with curiosity
doesn't mean you can convert everybody
um but lead with curiosity and and you
can be honest sometimes um you can
deliver honesty in a nice way honesty
doesn't have to be brutal um but you can
say to somebody
over time when you've tried everything
else hey um
you know i i have to believe that you're
not loving this company or you're
struggling with the team because we're
you know like you know i sometimes
struggle to connect with you and i know
it can't be one-sided so i'm struggling
to connect with you i have to believe
you're struggling to connect with me so
can we just address it and put it all
out on the table because we're more
likely to succeed if you and i can get
through this
so sometimes being honest about those
conversations where you just simply
point to and address the tension um in a
constructive way and that's worked for
me which is i don't think you're
enjoying your job because i know we're
struggling with with you and i struggle
with you and which i can't believe it's
one-sided i'm sure you're struggling too
can we work through this because i
really want you to be happy and i really
want you to enjoy it here and i really
want you if you could feel connected
with the team so can we just sit down
and talk it through
believe it or not that works very often
and if they're completely disconnected
then and toxic then protect yourself and
the team from them okay uh i think we
have time for like maybe one or two more
questions we have five more minutes so
we'll do two more questions
uh here's one from craig engels
hi craig uh if my age group of eight to
18 goes through a
a rigged system um how do i give others
the heads up on how to face the
challenges of today's world
craig you are thinking ahead um i so let
me try and interpret what you're saying
which is um
basically what you're saying is the
system isn't setting you up for reality
the system is setting you up for to
succeed in grades or wherever it is in
that system
it's not teaching you grit it's not
teaching you cooperation it's not
teaching you teamwork it's
teaching you put yourself first and look
how well you do if you put yourself
first um
how do you then communicate to your
friends of today's world
okay number one um you have to be doing
it yourself
uh
uh uh this is such a good question so
how do you do it with others i think you
need to adopt um
all the things we talked about i think
you need to be a student of leadership
um um number one put yourself like you
you can practice these things first um
and i think having conversations with
people i mean believe it or not saying
and don't make it about them make it
about us if you'll notice when i when i
do when i talk about things i very very
very rarely talk about you this and you
that i talk about us and we include
yourself um it's not it's less
aggressive and you say to a friend i
don't think you're instead of saying i
don't think you're prepared for the
future i say i don't think we're
prepared for the future make it
inclusive and if you can make it a wee
conversation where you put yourself in
that bucket they're more likely to
include themselves in that conversation
and and be a part of the solution so try
that i don't think we're prepared for
what the future holds i'm worried that
we're going through this and we're being
told that we're number one or we're
being told that it's all about us or we
can have anything we want in the world
and when we get to the real world we
won't be prepared um you know can you
help me
like
ask advice can you help me oh that's a
great one
i'll just tell a little quick story so i
have a friend who was going through a
really hard time career and personal and
she knows what i do for a living and so
she called me up and said will you help
me and i said of course and so we put
aside 90 minutes every single week where
we got together and i basically coached
her and
she told me what she was going through i
held space for her gave some advice and
she'd feel amazing for a day or two and
then she'd go back to feeling bad again
and we'd get together and she'd feel
amazing for a day or two and she'd go
back to feeling the same and this was
just a repeating pattern for weeks and i
felt like my goodness i wasn't making
any progress and i wasn't really helping
her and then i went back to my own work
i remembered service i remember that
from leaders eat last um
the the 12th step of the 12-step program
is to help somebody else who's
struggling with the thing
um you're struggling with um and about
asking for help rather than offering
help and so i called her up and said
listen we get together every week i
trust you more than anybody you trust me
more than anybody i have a favor to ask
and it was a genuine favor it wasn't a
trick it was a genuine favor i said can
we use some of the time for me to tell
you what i'm going through because i
welcome your advice too
and that's what we started to do i
started telling her all of my challenges
and all the things that i was struggling
with and all of my stresses and she
became the advice giver
and within a very few weeks all of a
sudden her personal life turned around
her professional life turned around when
she was helping me fix many of the
problems that she was dealing with she
was better able and better equipped to
solve the problems herself i found that
wonderful and amazing and so go back
and the struggles and fears that you
have
about what you are unprepared for in the
future go ask your friends to help you
get through that and amazingly by
helping you they're actually helping
themselves
okay so i think we're winding down now
people have been asking i just got a
note people have been asked about the
hoodie in the course okay so here's the
hoodie it says on it i'll read it to you
what does it say it says
the goal is not to be perfect by the end
the goal is to be better today and you
can see what it looks like i'll back up
i love it it's nice and soft um if you
want to get a hoodie i think there's a
link in the chat we're going to do that
okay and we did look at this we turned
on the special coupon for 24 hours
only for 24 hours okay so they turned on
the live 20 l
live 20 because we're live and it's 20
off uh if you want to get a hoodie
uh and then we can match and we can twin
and all that stuff um and if you we
somebody asked about the speaking course
if you go to simoncynic.com
somewhere on there in the uh on demand
courses uh you'll see the course for my
speaking class and if you put the code
in live 20 you'll get 20 off that also
for the next 24 hours
so i think that's where we are i
absolutely love doing these q a's
one day we'll get to do them in person
again and we can look at each other and
i can hear your voices
because that would be amazing um but
until then everybody thank you so much
for showing up thank you for coming from
all over the world for those of you it's
the middle of the night please please go
to sleep now it's way too late for you
to be on youtube and social media doing
this go to bed um uh and i and i think
if you want to refer back to any of this
i think we're going to put it online
which we usually do we'll put it on
we'll put it on our channel on youtube
if you want to go back and revisit any
of the answers um
thank you so much everyone um
until i see you next time take care of
yourself
take care of each other this is one of
my favorite favorite favorite things to
do is to engage and
chat and hang out and again i hope we
get to do it in person see you all soon
again take care of yourself take care of
each other